"FAULKNER FOCUS."
"OUTNUMBERED" NOW.
♪ ♪
LET’S START HERE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
REPORTEDLY PLANNING TO HOUSE UP
TO 3,000 MIGRANT TEENAGERS AT
THE DALLAS CONVENTION CENTER, AS
IT STRUGGLED TO FIND MORE SPACE
FOR THE SURGE OF MICRO’S OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
THE SITE WILL BE USED FOR UP TO
90 DAYS STARTING AS SOON AS NEXT
WEEK ACCORDING TO A MEMO
OBTAINED BY THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS.
THIS, AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORT RAISES ALARM ABOUT THE
CONDITION SOME OF THE KIDS ARE
LIVING IN, INCLUDING BEING
FORCED TO SLEEP ON GYM MATS WITH
FOIL SHEETS, AND GO FOR DAYS
WITHOUT SHOWERS.
MEANWHILE, HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN MCCARTHY HAS VISITED ONE
OF THOSE MIGRANT DETENTION
FACILITIES IN TEXAS AND WENT
AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE SAID, "HE SHOULD VISIT THE
BORDER HIMSELF TO SEE WHAT HIS
POLICIES HAVE CREATED."
>> I IT’S MORE THAN A CRISIS.
THIS IS A HUMAN HEARTBREAK.
THE SAD PART ABOUT ALL OF THIS,
IT DIDN’T HAVE TO HAPPEN.
THIS CRISIS IS CREATED BY THE
PRESIDENTIAL POLICIES OF THIS
NEW ADMINISTRATION.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO
CLAIMANT THAN A BIDEN BORDER
CRISIS.
>> Harris: BUT DHS SECRETARY
AL HUNTER MYRICK HAS ECHOED
THE WHITE HOUSE IN BLAMING
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMPS POLICIES
FOR THE SURGE, WHILE ALSO
DISMISSING SECURITY CONCERNS.
>> THE BORDER IS SECURE.
THE UNITED STATES BORDER PATROL
SECURES THE BORDER ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT WE DO, AND WE ARE
DOING IT.
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SAFE, GIVE US THE TIME TO
REBUILD THE SYSTEM THAT WAS
ENTIRELY DISMANTLED IN THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Harris: HOWEVER, HE ALSO
WARNED THAT DHS IS ON PACE TO
ENCOUNTER MORE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER THEN WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST 20 YEARS.
YOU ARE WATCHING "OUTNUMBERED."
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER.
HERE TODAY, LYCOS,
EMILY COMPAGNO.
HOST OF "NO INTERRUPTION" ON
FOX NATION, TOMI LAHREN.
FORMER SPOKESPERSON,
MORGAN ORTAGUS.
AND JOINING US TODAY, PUBLISHER
OF ""THE FEDERALIST,"" RADIO
HOST, AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
BEN DOMENECH.
GOOD TO SEE EVERYBODY.
THERE IS NO SPINNING OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO TO THE
BORDER, AND WE’VE HAD PLENTY OF
PEOPLE DO THAT.
TAKE A PEEK AT IT, TOMI LAHREN
HAS BEEN THERE.
I HAVE A HOUSE NOT FAR FROM
THERE.
WHY DO WE PUT MAYAYORKAS ON A JI
MATT, COVER HIM WITH FOIL, LET
HIM NOT SHOWER FOR A WEEK, AND
SEE IF HE HAS MORE IDEAS ON HOW
TO DEAL WITH THE SITUATION?
>> Ben: [LAUGHS]
THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE WAY TO
APPROACH IT.
IT’S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, AS
ALWAYS.
WHAT WE SEE ON THE BOARD ARE NOW
IS NOT HAPPENING THANKS TO THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTER HIS
POLICIES.
IT’S HAPPENING BECAUSE OF THE
INCENTIVES THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT IN PLACE.
IT’S WHY WE SAW THE NUMBERS
SPIKE IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY,
FAR EARLIER THAN YOU WOULD
EXPECT IN A NORMAL YEAR.
AND IT’S WHY WE ARE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH THIS PROBLEM IN A
SERIES OF ESCALATING DOMINO
EFFECT OVER THE COMING WEEKS AND
MONTHS.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT,
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
ATTITUDE TOWARDS MEXICO WAS
ESSENTIALLY VERY SIMPLE.
TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM ON
YOUR OWN SOUTHERN BORDER SO WE
DON’T HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT ON
OURS.
THAT WAS AN APPROACH THAT REALLY
WORKED.
FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
NOT JUST BECAUSE IT WAS IN THE
INTEREST OF MEXICO TO SECURE
THEIR SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THEY WERE FACING THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF TRADE THREATS
AND OTHER PRESSURE THAT COULD BE
PUT ON THEM FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY AN APPROACH
THAT THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
COMPLETELY DECRIED.
THEY SAID IT WAS INHUMANE, THEY
SAID IT WAS TERRIBLE.
WELL, WHAT IS THE HUMANITY
FACTOR NOW, WHEN YOU SEE THIS
ENORMOUS WAVE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, WHICH IS WHAT THIS
IS, THAT IS GOING TO FUEL THE
CARTELS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE MIDST OF A MAJOR DRUG
CONFLICT, A DRUG WAR, THAT IS
HAPPENING IN MEXICO RIGHT ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
THIS IS A CHAOTIC SITUATION, AND
NO AMOUNT OF EXCUSES FROM
MAYORKAS OR ANYONE ELSE WITHIN
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET AWAY FROM THE
FACT THAT THIS IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THEIR POLICY
DECISIONS.
>> Harris: BY THE WAY,
EVERYBODY, WE ARE LOOKING ALIVE
RIGHT NOW OUTSIDE THAT
CONVENTION CENTER IN DALLAS
WHERE THEY PLAN TO FILL THE
PLACE UP WITH TEENAGE MIGRANTS
COMING ILLEGALLY INTO THE
COUNTRY.
MORGAN?
>> Morgan: YES, MA’AM?
>> Harris: YOUR TOPLINE
THOUGHTS?
>> Morgan: IT’S INTERESTING,
HARRIS, YOU TALKED ABOUT A
DISMANTLING OF THE SYSTEM EARLY
ON WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATION, AND THERE WAS A
DISMANTLING OF THE SYSTEM, BUT
IT WASN’T BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE WILL LET ME BE WONKY FOR A
SECOND, THERE IS SOMETHING
RENEGOTIATED DURING
THE TRIP ADMINISTRATION.
TWO AGREEMENTS.
THEY ARE CALLED ACA ASYLUM
COOPERATION AGREEMENTS, AND BSA,
BORDER SECURITY AGREEMENT.
WE NEGOTIATED THESE WITH
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS, AND
EL SALVADOR.
I SPOKE TO A SENIOR DHS OFFICIAL
FROM THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
HE TOLD ME THAT THEY REPEATEDLY
WARNED THE BIDEN TRANSITION TEAM
NOT TO UNILATERALLY GET RID OF
THESE AGREEMENTS.
THESE WERE NOT ONE-WAY
AGREEMENTS, THEY WERE BILATERAL
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND THESE THREE
COUNTRIES RELATED TO EXACTLY
THIS, TO BORDER SECURITY, A
SILENT.
THEY WERE ALL SIGNED IN 2019.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE ARE SEEING
THE INFLUX TODAY IS BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO
GET RID OF THESE TWO ACAS AND
THE BSA WITH GUATEMALA,
HONDURAS, AND EL SALVADOR, AND
THEY HAD NOTHING IN PLACE.
NOTHING ELSE WAS NEGOTIATED WITH
THESE THREE COUNTRIES.
AGAIN, IT’S A BIT OF A WONKY
POINT BUT I THINK IT IS WORTH
KNOWING THAT THE TRUMP DHS TEAM
DID WARN THE INCOMING BIDEN TEAM
THAT THEY WOULD BE A SURGE AT
THE BORDER IF YOU GET RID OF
THOSE AGREEMENTS WITH THESE
THREE COUNTRIES WITHOUT ANYTHING
IN PLACE.
>> Harris: I WANT TO PRESS IN.
I WOULD NEVER CALL YOU WONKY,
YOU ARE EDUCATING US WITH THE
FACTS AND THAT COUNTS.
>> Morgan: [LAUGHS]
>> Harris: AS A JOURNALIST,
THAT’S ALL I EVER REALLY CARE
ABOUT!
SO I WANT TO ASK, NOT ONLY DID
THE FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
NEGOTIATE THESE ACAS AND BSAS
WITH THESE COUNTRIES, GUATEMALA,
HONDURAS, AND EL SALVADOR, BUT
AS I REMEMBER AND REPORTED ON,
HE NEGOTIATED THROUGH SOME TOUGH
TALKS, THE "KEEP THEM IN MEXICO
PENDING ASYLUM" REQUEST DEAL
WITH THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT.
THAT WASN’T EASY TO GET.
I’M GOING TO GUESS THESE THINGS
WEREN’T EASY TO GET.
SO, TAKING THESE THINGS APART,
IT DID WHAT?
DID THEY KNOW NOT TO TOUCH THOSE
POINTS?
YOU SAID YOU GAVE THEM A HEADS
UP.
>> Morgan: YEAH, SO I THINK,
HARRIS, WE APPROACHED IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OUR FOREIGN
POLICY FROM A POSITION OF
STRENGTH.
WHEN WE WERE GOING TO DO WITH
MEXICO, GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR, ON ANY ISSUES,
REMEMBER THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS NOT ONLY ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
THESE ACAS AND BSAS AND
AGREEMENTS WITH MEXICO, HE WAS
ALSO ABLE TO RENEGOTIATE THE
TRADE AGREEMENT WITH MEXICO,
SOMETHING PEOPLE THOUGHT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN WHEN A LEFTIST
PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED IN MEXICO.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE, WHEN
YOU APPROACH FOREIGN POLICY WITH
THESE COUNTRIES FROM A POSITION
OF STRENGTH, AND YOU SAY, "WE
ARE NO LONGER GOING TO ALLOW
THIS AT THE BORDER," AND YOU
MEAN IT, AND YOU FOLLOW UP WITH
MEANINGFUL AGREEMENTS AND
MEANINGFUL FORCE --
I WAS AT THE PODIUM WHEN WE
ANNOUNCED WE WERE CUTTING
FUNDING TO THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRY.
IT WAS NOT AN EASY DAY TO HAVE
TO ANNOUNCE THAT, BUT WE NEEDED
THOSE COUNTRIES TO KNOW THAT WE
MEANT BUSINESS.
>> Harris: TOMI?
>> Tomi: I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH THAT.
I THINK THAT’S AN EXCELLENT
POINT THAT NEEDS TO BE MADE.
BACK IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, HE DID THAT IN
MEXICO WITH TERRORISTS TARIFFS.
IT MAY MEXICO COOPERATE.
BACK WHEN THE CARAVANS ARE
COMING THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
AREA AND THROUGH TIJUANA, THEY
WERE NOT HAPPY.
THEY DIDN’T WANT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THERE, THEY DIDN’T
WANT THAT TESTING THEIR ECONOMY,
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE, THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY STARTED TO GET TESTS AND
THINGS STARTED TO CHANGE BECAUSE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TOOK THE PO
ANOTHER THING I LIKE TO DISCUSS
HERE, TOO, TALKING ABOUT THE
CARTELS AND THE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
WHILE THEY ARE FUNNELING ALL
THESE PEOPLE THROUGH, THROUGH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND SOMETIMES
SEX TRAFFICKING AND MAKING MONEY
OFF OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR DESIRE TO GET TO THE
UNITED STATES AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OUR PERKS AND PROGRAMS, THESE
DRUG CARTELS AND CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT JUST
GETTING PEOPLE ACROSS, THEY ARE
USING PEOPLE AND PUTTING THEM IN
A SINGLE AREA AND OVERWHELMING
THE SYSTEM, SO THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS HAVE TO PLAY BABYSITTER
AND TAKE CARE OF THOSE PEOPLE
COMING OVER.
WHILE THEY ARE OCCUPIED WITH
THAT, THEY ARE BRINGING THE
DRUGS THROUGH.
SO I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC, BUT ALSO AN OPIOID
EPIDEMIC AND A DRUG CRISIS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THOSE DRUGS COMING OVER WITH
THOSE CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS,
THEY ARE USING THESE PEOPLE AS A
SHIELD AND A DISTRACTION AND
THEY ARE SENDING THROUGH ALL
THESE DRUGS.
LAST YEAR WHEN I VISITED
McALLEN, AFTER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND TOUGH
POLICIES WERE PUT IN PLACE,
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WERE
TELLING ME, "WE ARE ALWAYS GOING
TO DEAL WITH CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND CARTELS TRYING
TO GET DRUGS OVER HERE, BUT NOW
OUR AGENTS CAN FOCUS ON THAT AND
WE ARE NOT FOCUSED ON BEING
BABYSITTERS, RUNNING PEOPLE TO
THE HOSPITAL, TO DETENTION
CENTERS, PROCESSING PEOPLE."
AGAIN, THIS IS BIGGER THAN THE
MIGRANTS COMING OVER.
IT’S ALSO DRUGS.
IT’S A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE,
IT BORDER SECURITY ISSUE, AND AN
ISSUE NOT JUST IN BORDER STATES
BUT ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
IT’S GOING TO FLOW UPWARD.
>> Harris: ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, WHICH IS WHY YOU SEE
THE ATTORNEYS GENERAL IN PLACES
LIKE MONTANA JOINING A LAWSUIT
WITH ARIZONA BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT THE METH COMING ACROSS, AND
OTHER DRUGS, GO THROUGH THAT
CORRIDOR, AND THEY’VE SEEN SUCH
A SPIKE OF THAT TYPE OF CRIME IN
THEIR STATE OF MONTANA.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
DURING THE LAST HOUR, AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON AT
THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WATCH.
>> AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
INSTITUTED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY, AND PUT UP A
BORDER WALL, IT WAS EFFECTIVE
AND IT WORKED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S ADMINISTRATION
HAS ACTUALLY CAUSED HUMANITARIAN
AND NATIONAL CRISIS AT OUR
BORDER BY OPENING THEM UP AT A
TIME WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE FIGHTING
TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS, OUR
BUSINESSES, AND OUR CHURCH IS
CLOSED.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY OPENING OUR
BORDER.
IT IS A TOTAL DISGRACE.
>> Harris: LOOK, EMILY, ONE OF
THE NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN HAS
SAID THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
AIDING AND ABETTING IN THE CRIME
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING WITH HIS
POLICIES.
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM SARAH SANDERS.
>> Emily: RIGHT.
I THINK AT A MINIMUM IT IS
CONSTRUED AS ENABLEMENT, HARRIS.
I LIKE TO DIG A LITTLE DEEPER ON
THESE CAPACITY LOCATIONS HERE.
WE KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
OPENING A TEMPORARY FACILITY IN
MIDLAND TEXAS AT A CAMP FOR
FORMER OILFIELD WORKERS.
WE KNOW A PROPOSAL IS BEING
CONSIDERED FOR THE NASA SITE IN
SILICON VALLEY, CALIFORNIA, NOW
IN HOMESTEAD, FLORIDA, A PLACE
OF FORMER HOLDINGS FOR UP TO
1700 MIGRANT CHILDREN, THAT IS
NOW IN WARM STATUS PAY WOULD IT
HAVE IN COMMON CONNECT THEY ARE
NOWHERE NEAR THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
EACH OF THOSE LOCATIONS BRING
WITH THEM A WHOLE HOST OF
CONSIDERATIONS FOR LOGISTICS,
FOR COSTS, AND FOR COVERT
EXPOSURE.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVING CONTROL
OVER THESE TEMPORARY FACILITIES,
PRIVATE OPERATORS ALONG THE
BORDER -- THIS IS
IMPORTANT -- PRIVATE OPERATORS
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT THEY EXPECT
INCREASES IN THE SURGE THROUGH
JUNE AND THAT THERE IS, QUOTE,
"NO PLAN IN PLACE BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO DEAL WITH
THEM."
THEY ARE LEFT OUT OF THE OUT IN
IT’S NOT JUST US TALKING ABOUT
THIS AND CALLING FOR ACTION,
SPECIFICITY, OR PLAN ON THE PART
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE ATTORNEYS GRANTED RESTRICTED
ACCESS DOWN THERE, AS WELL AS